I can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams
it must be very difficult
There's chaos in you
embrace it
Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
moon knight trailer video for the super bowl they
released a bunch of brand new footage so we'll
break it down if you're brand new to the channel
there were a bunch of super bowl trailers that
i'm still working through right now i'll do videos
for everything be sure to subscribe to get them
there was even a second doctor strange multiverse
of madness trailer video after the super bowl
that i'll do a separate video for on tuesday
as well with a bunch of different footage like
zombie doctor strange and zombie scarlet witch
that's right more zombies in the mcu after
what if and everybody's still freaking out
about patrick stewart professor x coming
back welcome to the mcu x-men mild shock
but in the brand new moon knight trailer footage
we actually get more of ethan hawke's villain
character now confirmed to be the dr arthur
harrow character from the early moon knight
comic book stories i'll explain what's going
on with his character because they're making
a couple changes from the comics he was a
little bit different in those old stories
but the showrunner said that they pitched
the story for moon knight as indiana jones
in the mcu so they're going for a lot of biblical
artifact references here like raiders of the lost
ark temple of doom last crusade with the ark of
the covenant the holy grail except that we're just
dealing with egyptian mythology egyptian artifacts
although if you haven't seen my other moon knight
videos i explain what's going on with Khonshu he
presents himself like the egyptian god of the moon
and that's the way they're building him in the mcu
here but secretly in the comics he's actually one
of the old gods just pretending to be the egyptian
god of the moon he's actually way way older and
way more powerful he comes from a pantheon of
elder gods that ruled over the mcu universe
millions of years ago if you think about earth's
history you talk about the eternals movie when
culture started to rise up the egyptian culture
was formed and they started worshiping their gods
he just presented himself to them as the egyptian
god of the moon like oh they're looking for gods
to worship i'll just present myself seems like
an opportunity here there's actually a scene in
the trailer where you see this purple lightning
coming down from the sky into this pyramid here
that actually might be the scene where moon
knight is getting his powers becoming the
avatar for konshu when he's outside in the
field of grass here in this black shirt and
brown jacket that seems like his original marc
spector mercenary personality he's got some
egyptian artifact konshu surprises him just
showing up behind him to give him some orders
usually Khonshu only appears to him when he wants
him to do something he's a very capricious god
like he'll just switch his moods on a dime he's
not a benevolent figure either like he's not a
loving god he only makes a deal with marc spector
to save his life because he wants something from
him like oh i see an opportunity here i need
somebody on earth to execute my will because he
himself is physically stuck in a pocket dimension
outside of the main mcu he's incredibly powerful
but he can't actually physically enter the mcu so
that's why he needs an avatar to execute his will
and at least initially it's all about Khonshu
getting revenge against people other gods that he
hates in most of the moon knight stories Khonshu
really hates the other gods we're going to meet
a lot of the gods of the mcu inside thor love and
thunder especially the ones we've only heard about
but haven't seen yet like for instance there's
a rumor that we're actually going to see bost
the panther god that black panther and his people
worship where he gets his powers from inside thor
love and thunder the whole idea that gore the god
butcher is going around killing gods at the mcu so
it's a really easy opportunity for them to present
a bunch of gods that you've heard about in the mcu
but you've never actually seen on screen before
not gods in the sense of the celestials like the
eternals talk about the celestials irish and the
judge the other celestial host as if they are
gods but they're really just ultra powerful cosmic
beings which aren't the same thing as actual gods
the way they're playing with the voice over
dialogue at the beginning of the trailer too like
you see him when katya appears behind him he's
in his marc spector persona but the voice over
dialogue is him doing that weird accent as steven
grant in the different personality most of the
last trailer was him in the steven grant persona
with just like a little bit of marc spector. Marc
spector is the mercenary his original personality
like he came up through the military then he
became a mercenary then he became moon knight
and then the other personalities were developed
but they might play it in a slightly different way
during the moon knight series the way the synopsis
for the show reads it actually sounds like a
roshaman type of story the way they tell like
you actually meet the steven grant personality but
then throughout the course of the story he finds
out that that's not the real original personality
and then he starts to question it like in the last
trailer where the woman calls him on the phone
and calls him by his marc spector name and he
doesn't know who that is like wait a minute who's
marc who are you talking to my name's steven grant
this scene in the bathroom is him looking
in the mirror and seeing his marc spector
personality staring back at him but the slightly
crazier one seems like the steven grant one
the one that seems more sure of himself more
hardcore is the marc spector mercenary personality
so when he actually becomes moon knight like when
the costume unfurls around him usually in the
comics that's marc spector moon knight like the
original personality although they just revealed
another personality from the comics the mr knight
persona you may have seen that picture in your
feeds in the last couple of days when he's wearing
the white suit and tie version of his costume here
like he almost seems like deadpool in this scene
this is mr knight and it's a personality that was
created relatively recently in the comics by
warren ellis and when he's in this personality
he's usually consulting with local police officers
being a detective just solving crimes which is
what it seems like he's doing in this scene here
on the tv show in these episodes i don't know
if they're actually going to present this as if
it's the actual separate mr knight personality or
if he'll just go back to being marc spector when
he's like this like if they're going to simplify
it and only do a couple of the personalities
because right now it only seems like they're
doing two different personalities marc spector and
steven grant but there might be a couple surprises
explaining a little bit more about ethan hawke's
villain character so arthur harrow in the comics
was from the early moon knight stories he wasn't
a huge character but based on the trailer footage
they've changed the character a little making him
a little more supernatural in the original comics
he was this former nazi scientist who suffered
from a condition that left him paralyzed on
his left side and in constant pain in his field
of study like he was a scientist for the nazis
was in pain itself so you kind of get his
motivation like he's in constant pain he starts
studying pain trying to find a way to control it
he does all these illegal experiments he gets in
a bunch of trouble but then later he shows
up as a moon knight villain doing more legal
experiments and pain on different people now ethan
hawke's version of the character on the tv show is
wielding all these egyptian artifacts you see him
wielding something with a bunch of energy coming
out of it like it seems like his walking cane
that he uses he walks around with all the time
is an egyptian artifact that allows him to wield
some special power it seems like he understands
kind of what's going on with moon knight maybe he
knows a little bit more about his connection with
Khonshu than he lets on he might be after some of
the similar god tier power that moon knight has as
a result of his connection with Khonshu and then
this sort of escalates to the indiana jones nazis
kind of place in the way that in those movies
you have nazis searching for biblical artifacts
to give them some sort of god tier power except in
moon knight we're talking about egyptian artifacts
but you get the reference ethan hawke's villain
character is this evil scientist searching for
egyptian artifacts to give him power early theory
they might be combining some of his storyline from
the comics with the sun king arc who's a character
that gains similar god tier powers from the god
that's conscious father amun ra there's a bunch
of different gods in the egyptian pantheon so he
could be stealing god to your power from any one
of those gods there's a big action scene with him
taking out a bunch of what seem like arthur herro
ethan hawke's character's goons here in the black
suits at this big estate you actually get to see
him in action wielding some of his main weapons
those are the crescent darts they're like his
version of batarangs they're like his trademark
weapon because there's so much crazy crossover
energy between different franchises happening
in doctor strange multiverse of madness you have
all this fox marvel stuff coming in through the
multiverse fantastic four x-men easter eggs i know
that a lot of questions about what moon knight
is going to be crossing over with in the movies
because it's a little bit darker more supernatural
like the doctor strange movies the only thing i've
heard up to this point is the rumors that it's
going to have a connection with the blade marvel
movie with mahershal ali's blade movie and thus
eternals kit harington's black knight character
because they are much darker characters in the mcu
and it sounds like kevin feige is doing a darker
team up in the background like on one level you
have the avengers movies where a bunch of the
big a-list characters cross over for really big
wtf problems we had the marvel netflix shows with
the defenders where you have street level people
teaming up to deal with street level problems
now that we have all these darker supernatural
characters coming to the mcu or new versions
coming to the mcu it sounds like kevin feige
is building a darker team up like marvel hearts of
darkness or midnight suns something in that vein
so there might be some references and connections
to that especially the blade movie at the end of
the moon knight series but that's about it it's a
pretty short trailer if you spotted any of the big
easter eggs in it that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the comments i'll
link my other moon knight trailer video at the
end of this too with a bunch of different footage
like i said i'll do a video for that other second
dr strange multiverse of madness trailer video
with the different footage tomorrow be sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that everyone click here for my video for that
first big trailer with all the x-men professor
x footage in it and click here for my other big
moon knight trailer video with all the different
footage thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!